usually does the whole name game
who is this
and who am i
and who are you
and where's my kiss
this season on lauren and alexi after
the 90 days okay
nice
good job oh my gosh shy are you walking
i know that there are so many fans that
are super excited that you finally have
your own spin-off it feels like this
should have happened a long time ago but
it's finally here
what made you say yes to the opportunity
i mean i've only been manifesting it
since i was born so
yes
but i had more concerns you know i'm i'm
more of like
you know behind the scenes person i
don't really want to be in front of it
all the time that much
lauren is the star and i'm just you know
i'm i i get the support and enroll he's
the supporting role right right but you
know what the truth is we'll be able to
look back on this and say that we did it
you never say i'll never do it again
then i wish i did so yeah yeah and how
did baby shower react to having all the
cameras around i know that probably was
an adjustment for him he loves
he was kind of born into it yeah
he's as well unless he's his mother's
child huh a million percent he never
passes the mirror without looking at
himself they're not he's gorgeous
thank you look
he's adorable well in the teaser we see
some big arguments between you two i
literally ask you to do one thing
i want to hear that one more time
how do you feel about you know fans look
at you two as a perfect couple so
they do perfect couples do they fight
and then they make up
that's true very true so how do you feel
about fans getting to see that side of
your relationship
like you said perfect couples argue it's
just a matter of how they handle it
you know some arguments are worse than
the other some linger
longer than others but
i i think it's relatable i mean
if somebody doesn't fight then
are you a robot like
right
right are you worried about
others perceptions of you changing at
all or is that
irrelevant
i think we've changed it i mean it
doesn't matter
once you once you decide to be on this
and show your life you have to be able
to handle the there's good and bad yeah
yeah
well it seems like you two are going to
open up about your sex life or laugh
with garage
what is that this time around we stopped
having sex it was not regularly already
before that
and you know when i spoke to you about
90 day foodie
from
people were so interested in your sex
life you have a great sex life
yeah i mean
you're like yeah i mean so now
they're getting what they want what went
into
your decision to open up more about that
i mean my my lingerie has changed over
the years
i think my frustration is what made it
open up about it more
we're still married
right i got two kids so we obviously you
know
had to do it to get the kids oh yeah
yeah well
look at this little chopstick i'm so
distracted right now that should chime
you make it bigger look at those
eyes
it's so cute
do you want to come say hi
dai come say hi the fans would love to
see you
he will never say no to the camera oh
who is this
baby shy
thank you
very nice because there's a pretty lady
there
he loves the ladies and i'm very
ready
he has girlfriends and they're all
ranging from two to four
what don't get me started i don't know
where she got that
the pool no one knows
she knows
well i want to talk about asher too
he was born premature
um he spent some time in the nicu is
that experience going to be shown like
the entire experience are fans going to
be able to see that
i mean some of it yeah it's definitely
an experience i'll never forget
and i have a whole new respect for
people who go through it yeah what what
did it teach you or what did you take
what was your biggest takeaway from that
experience
i'm just appreciation
and patience
and
you know not i don't wanna expectations
don't have expectations on anything hmm
yeah because you expected everything to
go
slower than normal and just during the
experience of it there were expectations
that were up and down and all around and
disappointments and you know but i feel
like seeing the nicu for for quite a
while
made me like think that it can all be
always be worse and
just appreciate what you have and you
know don't complain
yeah it
i mean now you have commitment yeah i
know it's what it is we're done
wow lauren's parents are always giving
me a hard time and sometimes i think
some space would be a good thing alex
we're gonna see you go back and forth
with lauren's parents your in-laws
is that is that how your relationship
dynamic is or was you just a moment talk
to us a little bit about that it's all
you honey
you know like any good relationship
there's ups and
you know in-laws relationship i love
them they're great
and they're very
involved
[Music]